border patrol agents are overwhelmed
with the massive influx of illegal
immigrants the number are like anything
we've ever seen border patrol saying
they have encountered 12,000 illegal
immigrants on the southern border that's
on Tuesday alone that's the highest
daily total ever Senator Lindsey Graham
with this message for President
Biden if you're awake you better come up
with a solution to a broken border
before a bunch of people get killed this
is a national security disaster in the
making bill maluan is at the Border in
lukeville Arizona he is near a huge
group of illegal immigrants now waiting
to be processed uh this matter just
getting worse by the day
bill it is jul and CBP sources tell me
in the last 24 hours alone there have
been just short of 10,000 migrant
encounters here at our Southern border
more than 3,000 of those happening right
here in this Tucson Arizona sector we'll
show you the situation here in lukeville
Arizona middle of nowhere Southern
Arizona Desert 2 hours to the closest
major city where people continue to
cross here illegally from all over the
world you can see the demographics here
all these guys adult men a lot from
African countries we talked to guys who
uh came in from morania Morocco Liberia
India Syria all over the place many of
them telling us they first flew into
South America then traveled through a
big handful of countries to get into
Mexico then went right through Mexico to
the Border here with the US where
they've crossed illegally and they are
expecting to be least into the United
States and all have cities where they
would like to go we'll show you what it
looked like earlier this morning take a
look at this before the sun came up we
were shooting this video it gets cold
out here so these migrants start
campfires all over the place in an
effort to stay warm they'll go into the
desert and pull brush out light it up uh
they'll find trash they basically
anything they can find to stay warm out
here because it does get uh pretty
chilly and some of these guys have been
camping out here for several days
waiting for border patrol to process
them we talk about the non-stop flow
here take a look at this video we shot
late yesterday afternoon there was
another breach in the border wall and
you'll see masses of hundreds of people
crossing illegally and then walking down
the dirt path on this border wall right
to where I'm standing giving you this
live shot border patrol is overwhelmed
they're trying to process people out of
here as fast as they can but it's hard
because there is a NeverEnding supply of
people coming through the border wall
and crossing here illegally we've had a
chance to talk to a lot of the guys out
here uh almost all of them have said
they are not seeking Asylum they're here
for opportunity for work in the United
States or they want to link up with
their family and they all have cities
they're planning to go to here take a
listen where in the United States do you
want to go Detro California New York
City New York City I have family members
therei Omaha Nebraska
Mii
Oklahoma Carolina espanol okay and back
out here here live you can see some of
these guys down
here
Ecuador New York New Jersey don't they
Chicago Chicago all right so you hear
there just a few blue cities right
there they're saying it's very cold they
don't have anything to cover their faces
a lot of them have been asking us for
food so you hear it right there guys all
these migrants have different cities in
the US they'd like to go to we hear a
lot of those Sanctuary cities New York
City and Chicago we'll send it back to
you W all right Bill malan thank you
very much Republican senator Joanie
Ernst of Iowa members of the armed
services committee and a US Army Combat
veteran joins me now um I want to talk
to you about you know the issue first of
all at the border the migrant Crossing
you know obviously is surging to
Historic levels 12,000 illegal
immigrants crossing the border on
Tuesday alone what does that tell you
well it tells me that President Joe
Biden on the first day that he came into
office he made a grave Mistake by
getting rid of uh the previous
administration's policies he threw open
President Biden did threw open the door
to the United States of America now we
have this humanitarian crisis at the
border with as you stated over 12,000
people now per day entering the United
States illegally there is no way to
process all of these people and of
course we know that simply stating you
want a job in the United States of
America is not a reason for Asylum so
again uh we had some of those policies
right in the previous administration
President Joe Biden needs to own up to
this admit that he was wrong and
reinstate the policies of the past and
allow us as Senate Republicans to
proceed with our border policy changes
there are major cities also struggling
with a mass migrant influx a new poll uh
actually shows 85% of New York City
voters are concerned about the city
accommodating migrants and in
Massachusetts alone hotels there have
actually cancelled bookings of veterans
and their families for the Army Navy
football game being played in Foxboro
this weekend and those rooms are
actually instead housing you guessed it
migrants and Senator tell us about the
letter that you wrote this week to the
Biden Administration demanding action
yes these border patrol or excuse me the
Border policies that Biden has in place
which allowed all of these migrants to
come into the United States has now
created an issue even this weekend at
America's game which is the Army Navy
game we know that Massachusetts has laws
in place one of which is the shelter uh
the right to shelter law which provides
shelter for those that are refugees or
illegal migrants coming into the United
States so what's happening now all of
those families that are attending this
game on behalf of their midshipman or
Cadet those army veterans those Navy
veterans that will be attending even
active duty Personnel that are flowing
into the Boston Massachusetts area they
have had their hotel reservations
cancelled why yes because of illegal
migrants that are being housed by the
City by the state in these hotels where
reservations had previously been made so
instead of watching in the comfort of a
hotel room for this Army Navy game we're
housing illegals yeah and and you just
heard Bill maluan speak with a few
illegals there and many of the states
they wanted to travel to were Democratic
cities why because they're getting free
housing we've got multiple beautiful
former luxury hotels here in New York
City that have been shut down and
they've been handed over to these
migrants uh I got to move on to
President Biden's green agenda it took a
big hit as you know last night the house
striking down his administration's
mandate designed to speed up the
transition to electric vehicles
something so many Americans don't want
nor can they afford uh it wasn't just
Republicans though who voted against
Biden's EV push five Democrats crossed
the aisle to vote down the regulations
one Republican Congressman with this the
issue here is people are not choosing
EVS yet they don't think they're
affordable they don't think they're
attainable they don't think they're
reliable and it's not a reality for them
all we're asking is that people have
choice and that choice may be EVS but
don't mandate it I love he just said
people need to have a choice because
don't Democrats uh Echo that sentiment
when it comes to women and many other
things you need to have a choice but not
when it comes to your vehicle what in
the heck this makes no sense and most
people can't afford an electric vehicle
nor do they want to be bothered with
having to find somewhere to charge it no
I am I am right there with you I think
it is absolutely ridiculous that this
Administration has been pushing electric
vehicles on the American people if you
go to my home county of Montgomery
County in southwest Iowa really rural
area no EVS are not reliable there is
nowhere to charge them you can't drive
to a City without needing a charge and
and of course the cost it is more than
most families of four in my hometown
make in a year so of course we are
pushing back on the EV mandate and I'm
glad to see House Republicans take up
that charge I have been working
literally no pun intended that charge um
but uh I have been pushing back on this
in the senate for a very long time you
know we don't need to Source these cars
that that have materials that are built
or or brought in from China uh these
batteries that are made with child and
slave labor really is this what we're
trying to push on the American people I
think not and the house has spoken all
right Senator Joanie Ernst thank you you
have spoken as well and we appreciate it
appreciate it thank you see you next
time hey everyone I'm Emily compano
catch me and my co-hosts Harris vulner
and Kaylee mechineni on outnumbered
every weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or
sets your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights